عن ازمه البكيني في لبنان يعني هو العنوان
بشد ومستغرب نوعا ما شو تفاصيل يرينا
راويه وعادل انا مجددا عندي مشاكل مع
الهوى هلا
طيب احكي لنا تفاصيل عن ازمه البكيني
اه نعم نعم يعني لا تزال تداعيات الحادثه
التي تعرضت لها سيده كانت تلبس المايوه
على على شاطئ صيدا الشعبي وزوجها بعد ان
تعرض لها رجل دين ومجموعه من الشبان وتم
طردهم من الشاطئ تتفاعل تفاعلات كثيره
وصلت الى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والى
وسائل
الاعلام ايضا وانتهت يعني نوع من الانقسام
العمودي بين من هم مؤيدون لذلك
صيدا البحري يوم الاحد
حراكا مضضا بين الفريقين كل يريد ان يدافع
عن رايه فبين مؤيد يرى في ذلك ضروره
للحفاظ على هويه صيدا المحافظه برايه وبين
من يرى في ذلك يعني تعدل على الحريات
الشخصيه وخاصه على شاطئ عام طبعا هذه
المواجهه بين شبان وشابات من المجتمع
المدني والجمعيات النسائيه وبين محافظون
وابناء من المدينه من جهه اخرى انتهت يعني
فصل بالقوى الامنيه وبعض المناوشات الا
انها يعني لم تنتهي
اقفال الجدل حول هذا الموضوع طبعا يعني
لبنان كما تعرفون عادل وراويه هو بلد
متنوع وهو بلد يعني يسعى قدر الامكان الى
تحقيق الحد الاكبر من المساواه طبعا حصلت
حوادث مماثله منعت محجبات من دخول الى
مسابح خاصه فقط لانهن محجبات وحصل ان منعت
خادمات من الدخول الى
المسيمه قانون اللبناني يعني لا يمنع او
يسمح بالبكيني او البركيني
يعني هنا في مكان عام
وبالتالي شكرا جزيلا مراسله صباح العربيه
في لبنان واستمتعي بالهويات الجميله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات